MARGARET KOVAL: I
want to drill down
on the actual work
behind the Nobel.
It was for the directed
evolution of enzymes.
And you describe yourself
as a protein engineer,
which, if I understand
it correctly,
means you get under the hood of
these proteins, these enzymes,
and tinker with them to
make them do something
that they don't do naturally.
Can you explain why anybody
would want to do that?
Why enzymes?
FRANCES ARNOLD: If you
look at how biology takes
renewable resources, simple
starting materials like carbon
dioxide and sunlight, and
converts that into life,
into living
organisms, the enzymes
are the catalysts, the
workhorses of life that
do that magical transformation.
So when I saw an enzyme
for the first time
and realized what a beautiful
molecular machine this was,
I said, that's what
I want to engineer.
MARGARET KOVAL: Your work
started maybe 25 years
ago or so.
What has been the outcome in
the last couple of decades?
FRANCES ARNOLD: These
methods are sufficiently
simple that they
propagated to laboratories
all over the world.
For example, Merck makes
some of their biggest drugs
using enzymes that replace
toxic metals that they used
to use in chemical
processes and really reduced
the waste footprint of
making pharmaceuticals.
The enzymes you find in
your laundry detergent that
take stains off
clothes -- nature never
made an enzyme that likes to
work in laundry detergents,
but people bred them using
my methods to work very well.
Enzymes help you use much
less energy so you don't
have to use high temperatures.
MARGARET KOVAL: Why
would a young person
go into chemical engineering
or bioengineering today?
What might we see in 30
years as a result of it?
FRANCES ARNOLD: I
personally would
love to see a chemicals
industry that's
based entirely on clean,
green biological processes.
Replace these
factories with bacteria
to make what we need
in our daily lives,
and do it from
renewable resources.
MARGARET KOVAL: I'm
going to spin you back
if I can a little bit
to when you started here
at Princeton University.
What kinds of other
courses did you take?
I know that you're a
linguist, for example.
FRANCES ARNOLD: I took a
lot of language courses.
I took Russian.
I took Russian literature.
Those were fabulous courses.
I took economics.
I took developing
world economics.
I took Marxist theory.
I did all sorts of things
that you wouldn't normally
find on the engineer's docket,
but it made an educated person
out of me.
MARGARET KOVAL: Yeah.
But do you think it helped feed
the creativity that ultimately
made you successful
as a scientist?
FRANCES ARNOLD: I
can't imagine not
being able to read and write
and make these connections
from literature and philosophy
that have helped inform
my understanding of evolution.
So the answer is clearly yes.
MARGARET KOVAL: Now
and forever more you're
going to be considered a
role model for women in STEM.
Is that something
that you embrace?
FRANCES ARNOLD: So
what I want to do
is encourage women to take
on this incredibly exciting
and fun challenge,
to use their brains
for the benefit of humanity
through science and technology.
Don't let the guys have this.
This is great career material.
MARGARET KOVAL: Right.
Well, OK.
With that, I'm going to say
thank you very, very much
for joining us, Frances Arnold.